dans son potager
madame wang cueille de la citronnelle
mais on a un boxeur étape seuil chase
home gansu chinois elle cultive sur ses
terres plus d'une trentaine de légumes
asiatiques
c'est la productrice du risen affres et
les cheveux
on est sur la paire défaite groulx
afrique burg aussi de mauriac est à une
classe mon copain il fait les légumes
biologiques qui fait du sirop d'érable
médiatique
une façon pour moi de me reconnecter
aussi avec mes origines
donc c'est des légumes des fois que moi
je cultive que j'ai pas vraiment grandi
avec alors c'est intéressant de le
découvrir en même temps que je les fait
découvrir aux autres
la culture d'aliments asiatique est
grandissante depuis quelques temps en
ontario ici c'est un marché que tente de
développer stefan jung avec des produits
comme le lui faut plus connu sous forme
d ponge que de légumes
c'est dans la famille des cucurbitacées
ça s'apparente un peu au zouk unis ou au
concombre et à l'intérieur on ne cherche
qui ressemble aux docks unis mais qui
est plus sucrée est très aéré très
moelleuse un peu comme si on craint
qu'un dans un nuage
on récolte du mizuna c'était une verdure
une tarte douce japonaise qui est
amertume dans la famille du chou
là c'est fait la première coupe donc ici
pertes en fait c'est une variété de
bodoï
les feuilles sont plus foncées sont
ronds sur le fun a ajouté dans les faits
il ya un petit goût de noisette s'attend
plus faire un peu un mix avant clip
inari le botteur quand il est jeune
comme ça les faits sont bien tendres et
encore un petit peu croquantes
c'est super bon donc ça c'est du tri
saumon la récolter ce matin c'est comme
le brocoli chinois puis tout se mange la
feuille le bouton la tige
ça peut être mangée crue où ça peut être
cuits à la vapeur
deux minutes c'est vraiment bon c'est
sucré chaque semaine elle sera à
montréal c'est au marché de la rue
prince-arthur qu'elle s'installe pour
vendre tous ses produits et toute la
famille puis à mettre l'épaule à la roue
on perd en vie bonjour damas à carling
et ma tante daniel ben je pense que la
communauté chinoise en général de l'eure
c'est très important la famille comme le
projet quand même il y ait beaucoup à à
nos cultures
alors je pense que çà çà çà nous ratons
j'allais voir son moteur avec la salle
sa barbe eux aussi leurs familles
d'orques mémoire maire de la rochelle
j'aime la montagne mais j'ai jamais et
déguster un verre de leurs otages si la
première fois mais même dans la falaise
puis ça va donner
10 12 c'est surprenant à la base mais
finalement de riace accro à ces légumes
là on découvre de nouvelles recettes et
d'univers savoir donc c'est super
intéressant
quelqu un qui moi seulement curieux
comme si pas beaucoup les légumes
asiatiques mais j'aime beaucoup la
nourriture asiatique et donc je suis
l'ex trader semble acquise mais chez
nous stéphanie nous envoient chaque
semaine une lettre avec le nom des
légumes et aussi des conseils des
suggestions de recettes des miens
connaître la personne qui est derrière
mes légumes connaître le lieu la
provenance pour moi c'est une valeur qui
est vraiment supérieure à la chienlit
pis rigueur on a récolté évidemment mais
c'est la première année que jean qu'une
fille est dommage explique comment j'ai
liquidé le cuir
la bouille est là
puis à la vapeur 6 4 la mission durera
environ à faire découvrir les légumes
asiatiques dans les marchés locaux et
qui chance intéressante dans cette
démarche un peu ma famille la communauté
ou 6,5 les et puis donc l île parc
succès à transférer des connaissances
comment les cuisiner ces légumes ne le
lui faire enlever les corses
sinon c'est dur le légume et je
souhaitais d'abord je mis à part une
part qui a été basse airs et puis je
saute pas du chat joue tous ensemble
ma tante à faire beau plein donc c'est
une feuille des champions il ya du porc
avec des vermicelles de riz cru ou cuit
le légume ajoute aussi de la texture et
absorbe toutes les saveurs dans un plat
quelques erreurs qu'on a récolté cette
année afin de mizuno qui te tapes
douceur japonais
enfin le pesto au plh graines de
tournesol et huiles des façons simples
de varier les menus et de découvrir de
nouvelles saveurs comme avec cette
salade de shiso une feuille au goût de
cumin cannelle coriandre et à nice
je pense que je suis un des seuls à
vraiment se spécialiser la dent
en culture bio je pense qu'il va falloir
qu'il ya d'autres maraîchers qui
s'intéressent tous ces hauts lieux
médiatique parce que la demande est leur
puits un peu plus grande